I think failure would be capping off
where we were in 2012 it's roughly 1% of
the vote or lower I think going
backwards would be a failure if we don't
do better this time than we did in 2012
I would consider that to be a bad result
in a presidential campaign
well libertarians are always reluctant
to put a number on it but I will I will
go out there and say that in this
election with this opportunity anything
less than 3% of the National popular
vote the president should be regarded as
a failure
first target is to get to 5% because
once we had 5% we make ballot access a
lot easier for all the states I would
like to see us get between 10 and 15
percent failure for the Libertarian
Party you know I guess not getting into
the debates I would not be doing this if
there weren't the opportunity to
actually get elected but to do that the
only chance that a third-party candidate
has of getting elected is to be in the
presidential debates the presidential
debate commission says that you have to
be at fifteen percent in the polls key
for me right now is just being in the
polls then we get into national dialogue
and I think that 20% goes to 25 percent
and from that point it's Katie bar the
door and then anything is game at that
point
polls that are between 40 to even 50
percent of the general public do not
want Hillary Clinton or Donald Trump as
president hi
you know New Mexico give them a
electoral vote I think that would
definitely shake things up to garner
enough electoral college votes to
prevent the other two candidates from
getting a plurality would be a success
itself and truly of the highest order to
be honest with you we could get
Republicans really to jump on board and
we could get some Bernie you know
disenfranchise Bernie supporters I mean
we could win the presidency I mean
there's there is an opportunity there
because if there are three parties there
with two months ago or a month and a
half ago or even even a month to go and
it's forty five thirty five twenty five
that's too close for the pundits to
write anybody off in a crazy year like
this and 2016 results are a springboard
to mass defections and the destruction
of at least one of the old parties
basically the ideal is to follow the
line of the wigs when they basically
fell apart and turned into the
Republican Party it's time for the
Republican Party to fall apart and go
away or the Democratic Party I don't
really care which but at least we would
get to a point where you basically have
a plurality system in this country we
would break the two-party system and
make it a three party system so that
there are actual political options